- There are many myths about consulting.
One example of things I frequently hear
is that often in consulting projects,
the result is already decided
at the beginning of the project,
meaning the consultant
just write down the things
that the management of
the client is wanting them
to drive down anyway.
Is all of this true?
These are the things
that I'm going to discuss
in this video today.
I'm reviewing the three most common myths
that I frequently heard about consulting.
So when it comes to another
video here on my channel
Firm Learning today, it's
quite warm here Munich,
so I'm not drinking a
coffee, but just a water.
Hope that's fine for
you as well as you know,
my name is Heinrich, on my
channel I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
But now without further ado,
let's jump into the three
myths and let's have a look,
whether these are actually true or not.
So let's start with myth
number one about consulting.
And this is likely the thing
that I hear most frequently
when people talk badly about consultants.
And this is that
consultants just write down
what other people on the
client side tell them
to write down anyway.
So pretty much implying that
the results of the project
are already clear, already defined
from the beginning of the project
and consultants are just
there to make it look good
just to provide justification
for maybe some harsh measures
that the management wants to take anyway.
And what these people
mean is that sometimes
there is senior management
may be off a client.
This senior management wants
to do some harsh measures
with the organization.
Often this will be
related to cost cutting,
maybe even deciding to
let go of employees,
off people in the organization.
And they don't want to
do that on themselves.
They just ask consultants to come in
and just to do a project,
to investigate these things.
And then in the end, just to write down
what they wanted to do in the first place.
So what is my view on that?
And in general, personally,
I consider this perspective to be fraud.
I never experienced a situation
where at the beginning of a project,
it was clear what the
result was supposed to be.
I never was in a meeting with a partner
or any other senior personnel
of a consulting firm
telling the team, explaining to the team
that this is now the task.
This is what we need to
write on a piece of paper.
This is what the client wants.
Of course, that being said,
sometimes you find yourself in a situation
where the client already
has a couple of hypothesis
that the client shares with you.
So for instance, yes, it might
be that the client is looking
into cost cutting measures and
is asking you as a consultant
to evaluate these cost cutting measures.
And then of course, depending
on the agreed scope,
the result of that might be
that then you as a consultant
also propose things.
But in my perspective, this
is something very different
than just writing down what
the client tells you in the beginning.
Of course, you're going
to pick up some ideas
that the clients has.
Of course you will evaluate them,
potentially also incorporate
them in your final suggestion.
Then what is important
to understand is that
if a consulting firm
delivers a recommendation
to the client.
And this is of course, especially true
for MBB consulting firms
like McKinsey, BCG, or Bain.
The reputation of your firm
will be very much attached
to the quality of these recommendations.
Just as an example, I in
the past worked for a client
for a firm and several years ago,
they apparently did a project
with Boston Consulting Group,
with BCG and BCG developed
a strategy for this client.
And this document was
still being circulated
through the organization.
So this BCG strategy document,
and everyone just called the document,
yeah, the BCG document, the BCG strategy.
So clearly your name, your reputation
is often very directly tied
to the results of your work
and clearly big consulting firms,
just what they'll be able
to justify to themselves,
just to potentially
damage their reputation.
Do things, write things down
that they do not believe are true,
that they do not believe
our recommendation only
because any client is
asking them to do that.
This is just not how it works.
Let's talk about the
second consulting myth,
and this is that consulting
is nothing as the
glorified temporary work.
This would mean that as a consultant,
you're not really developing
new concepts and strategies
as an independent party,
but you are and the nothing,
it's just an extension of the workforce
for the employer for your client.
So maybe if a client
needs some extra capacity,
some extra things that need to get done,
but the client does not
have enough capacity
to get this done in-house
this will be then the
scenario where the client
is asking for consultants,
just to take them on as temporary
workers to do the things
that they cannot currently do
in their home organization.
And my perspective on this is,
well, there might be some truth to that.
Let me come to that in a
moment, what that would be,
I would argue that this is
largely completely exaggerated
and not really the case.
As a consultant and I'm specially talking
about MBB consulting firms,
so McKinsey, BCG, and Bain,
you pride yourself of delivering
an independent opinion
of delivering your analysis,
your view on the perspective
that you bring to the client.
Indeed in the normal consulting setup,
you are not directly reporting
to the client in the sense
that the client will tell
you what you have to do.
Of course the client, we
want to review your work.
We'll discuss this work with you,
but usually this will not
take the form of the client
exactly telling you what
the individual steps are
that they want you to complete.
And for sure, again, let's
discuss the myth number one,
they will not tell you what
the results of your work
are supposed to be.
So general, I disagree with this myth
and this was even something
that was also top of mind
of many partners I used to work with
that they always used to say,
so we don't want to do is just
to be the extended work bench
of the clients, just to get
some work done, get tasks done
that at the moment the
client cannot complete.
It should always be a part
of your independent opinion,
your perspective that
you bring to the table.
Though that being said,
I think there are two perspectives on this
where maybe you could come
to the conclusion that yes,
there might be some truth to that.
And the first is that the
things that I talked about
are very much true for MBB Consulting,
but might be less true for
other consulting firms,
maybe especially small or
Boutique Consulting Firms.
So while I don't wanna say
that this is usually the case,
there might be some consulting
firms where your work often
is indeed rather compare to temporary work
than to actually providing
an independent opinion.
And the second perspective
of this is that sometimes
especially in projects
that are already ongoing
for a long time project, that
got extension after extension,
after extension, often you are
really coming with the client
and to really a working
mode an operational mode
where you do tasks, agree on
next steps, agree on to dos.
So these are the situations
where then sometimes
the lines get a little bit blurry.
And here also the client just
might like to work with you
in this setting, because even
though your fees probably
are not really economical
to just use you as a
normal employee equivalent
for them maybe they just don't
have the budget approval,
not the means not to hire new people.
And it might just be easier for the client
to continue working with
you as a consultant,
even though your fees are much higher
than what they would pay to an employee,
just out of the convenience aspect of it.
So let's look at myth number three,
and this is that consultants
actually don't care
about their clients.
They just want to make as
much money as possible.
They just want to collect
their consulting fees,
their per diems from the clients,
and whether what they do then is creating
any actual value at all.
They don't even care about
that as long as they get paid.
And I find this way of talking about
this quite bitter to be honest.
So surely consulting firms as
every other firm is a business
after all we'll need
to think economically,
but this just means that
consultants don't care about
their clients and customers.
This just seems very wrong to me.
And just to illustrate that.
So at my former employer,
one of the highest values,
kind of the highest evolution
level of being a consultant
is really to become a trusted
advisor to the clients,
to the senior management, to
the people that you work with.
So whenever one of these
people would have a problem,
a business related issue
they wanted to discuss,
ideally they would think
about you top of their mind
about a person that
they can sit down with,
just use you as a sparing partner,
discuss some topics with
you then potentially
also then start a project
to address certain issues.
So surely deeply caring
about your clients,
deeply being concerned about
what really creates value
at your clients and has a positive impact
this from my experience,
from what I have seen
was always at the core
of every successful partner I worked with.
I'm not even once experienced
a situation where a partner
or any other senior person
of the consulting firm
would just barely imply anything like, oh,
this project probably will not go away,
but I don't care because
I will make lots of money
so that's fine.
I not even once in six
years working consulting
have I heard anything like this.
And again, it's of course
difficult now to speak
for every single
consulting firm out there.
Of course my experiences
are very much influenced
by the firm that I worked for.
But I would assume that at least
for the MBB firms, McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
this will be the trend.
This is the situation that you will face.
And this was also very well
reflected in the culture
and also the whole incentive systems,
how you were also evaluated
even as a junior consultant.
So you would always be rewarded
if you were able really
to come up with good ideas
that really helped the client.
If you came up with something
that really resonated,
had a positive impact that
really satisfied the client
and made an impact,
these were the things that
would make you be perceived
as a strong consultant as a rock star.
And frankly, if you set
up your work in a way
that you don't care about
your client's success,
but just about your own success,
I think this would be very, very difficult
because often just the
truth that these two
are very closely interlinked.
So the one regularly leads to the other
and the other way around,
which I think great,
because this just means that
the incentives are aligned.
So what do you think about these
big myths about consulting?
Do you think they are true?
What are your reflections on that?
We'd love to hear your
perspective, in the video comments,
to know whether you agree
with what I've said or not.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel,
to stay up to date on all my content.
I'm also active on other channels,
such as Instagram, TikTok, or Twitch.
You'll find the links to these channels,
in the video description.
Of course, as always also big thanks
to all the members of Firm Learning.
You're really making a great
contribution to the course.
Thank you for that.
My name is Heinrich from Firm Learning
was a pleasure doing this video for you.
See you again next week.
Good weekend to all of you and bye bye.